für mich war das klar dann brauchen wir
gar nichts vormachen
daran werde nicht sterben manchmal auch
benötigt unnötige hoffnungen zu haben
wir werden nicht einfach ganz ganz ganz
viel informationen
ich habe keine ahnung was meine
blutwerte bedeuten dass man die hand
gedrückt bekommen wenn nicht immer
nachgefragt haben dann dieses mal habe
ich doch gesagt natürlich aber und
vergessen machen und nicht sogar mehr
[Musik]
braucht ihr unterstützen
man kann nicht man kann nicht alles
allein im leben machen
allerdings haben wir die ist ein
mittelsmann geflossen sein
der formation the life and mail
das richtige ich weiß nicht wieder sein
wird ein abbau irgendwann einfach zu
wissen was ich genau das leben gelebt
habe dass ich nehmen wollte
[Musik]